hi thanks so much I'm really excited to
be here this I believe the 6th time I've
spoken for Jared I'm at conferences and
meetups and it gets more fun every time
as my first time in DC are so really
excited to be here so my my talk starts
with the experience of who hers who's
heard of the tiny Tuesday project isn't
it fantastic
it's a project run by the by the arc for
data science online learning community
and every week they release a data set
to the data science community and say do
anything you can you can analyze it make
graphs do analyses and what inspired me
to do is start on opening the data set
each week and then recording myself
analyzing it so I've ended up doing 36
tidy Tuesday screencasts in the last
year so I spend an hour with each data
set dive in learn some things about it
and post the UM the recording on YouTube
so it's been really fun but so here's an
example I'm so like how I'm exploited
it's at a trying out building a network
graph I think yeah and then I started
working from there and it's been really
fun to like to learn about myself and
learn about some of the um how I feel
what we're working with new data and
really practicing that skill but it's
also been a blast to hear from people
that say what they learned from the
screencast because it's not always what
I expect one that I found out is that
all of us are walking around with tricks
things we know how to do with our or in
an often in my case with the tidy verse
that we might not think of as a as an
obscure trick but that is a critical
part of our workflow and might help
other people so with that I decided I'd
go kind of a clickbait route and say
here are my 10 tricks that only a tidy
verse user free will appreciate number 6
will blow your mind
and really dig and really just walk
through rapid-fire series of um of
things that you may or may not know from
that you can do in the tidy verse each
of the times I'm actually really
interested
the first time I'm giving this talk I'm
really interested in learning what does
everybody already know what might be
extremely obscure what's somewhere in
between so I'm going to ask about each
trick who has already heard about it
sound good so these are ten tricks
they're going to be combined into kind
of themes first a couple of tricks I
found around counting and summarizing
data second one about ggplot2
visualization and for cats for
categorical data and third three tricks
from Tidy are that are some of its levy
less are less well-known functions from
the package so first I'm going to start
with my favorite function count
whoever's used count in deep layer
before fantastic so the UM so had Lee
Wickham has said that most of data
science is counting and sometimes
dividing and I find you can get a really
long way just with counting data so in
fact I did a little analysis of all of
the screencasts that the African
screencasts that have done and actually
found the count was the fourth most used
function them after mutate filter in
group five so I really do love counting
what would I do with count this was one
of the a lot of the examples gonna show
come from my tally Tuesday screencast
just because it's a lot of code I have
lying around where I've used these
tricks this was one from the first
screencast they did where I counted the
number of times each no graduates of
each major so in this case this was a
table that includes that divided college
majors down into categories and show
here's the UM there are ten majors in
agriculture and natural resources eight
in the arts so some of you may have used
count this way did you know it has three
additional arguments sort weight and
name sort lets us say well we're gonna
we're going to count the number of times
each category appears but then we're
gonna sort the result in descending
order to find the largest first wait
means that instead of finding the number
of observations I'm gonna sum up a
column in this case I say the weight is
total which means I'll sum up the total
number of graduates column and find the
number of graduates in each and third it
the result doesn't have to
named n it can be named graduates so uh
but you can give a name equals graduates
I think that's new as a deep hi are
0.8.0 fairly recent it's really in this
trick you get three tricks for the price
of one who's you sort and count before
who's used wait who's used name it's
awesome so is the first trick the second
trick is another way to use a group by
or count we've seen that you can count
one of the existing columns for example
here was a dataset of bridges from from
Maryland Maryland and what year they
were built so I had this cowboyed say
how many times was each built but I
might not want to count the number of
how many built bridges were built in
each year but I might not want to count
than the it by year I might want to
count it by decade so in the same
process of the count I can create a new
column kind of like a mutated then
account so the UM and then it ends up
with a data set that's actually
aggregated by decade 1900 1910 1920
instead of being aggregated by year so
in fact there's a trick ten times year
this truncated division ten it's a way
you can add great years in a decade
which offers a bonus trick within this
one who I already knew that you could
create two new variables in a group by
your count it's actually more obscure
than I expected but it's a really that's
a really a fun trick it saves you an
extra step of creating a variable so the
graph like this I would under a data set
like this I'm end up taking this doing a
G on line and sir the number of bridges
built in each decade third is add count
who's ever used the add count function
in dir is always added I think about
three years ago it's a little bit more
is a little bit more obscure who has
ever had to do this a group I mutate
than done group where all you're adding
in is N equals n it's really helpful I'm
going to see a couple case where it's
helpful the UM
this is a three step process where I'd
say we want to add this end column and
say here the four in these four
observations the total for that loop is
four in the 2 for B it's 2 in this one
for C it's 1 and that can be done in one
step of add count columns so taking
three steps and putting them into one
where I find this really useful is to
combine it with the filter so if I say
add count and then filter add so this
was a data set of space launches for
particular us space vehicles and I
wanted to and because I said add count
to a particular variable then do a
filter on that end I was able to
visualize only the vehicles that had at
least 20 launches so add count and
filter is a combination I like to play
with here a third way that I really like
to aggregate data Islam with summarize
is creating a list column this is a
relatively recent behavior of deep I I'm
not sure if it was introduced last year
the year before but you can use
summarize to create a list column so I'm
going to pull out a tidy Tuesday data
set of New York City restaurants and
this was a this was actually of
inspections of them and and showing what
for this restaurant how many times was
it inspected and what was the average
score we're more we're a higher score
means more violations now I could find
the average inspection score with a
group by and a summarize so a group by
summarize mean average score and I've
added a column called AVG score with
that value but did you know that if you
put a list as the as the output in that
summarize you don't end up with a value
you end up with a list column so this
field in in out in the result is
actually a list and every one of these
objects is a t-test so we could put kind
of anything into that summer into that
summarize equals list and anything we
put in there is going to be turned into
an object in this list column
so why would we want to create a table
of many objects that would cover a much
larger scope than what I have the time
time to talk about today but here's a um
one example is we could take those use
the broom package to tidy them and then
visualize multiple models just here it
shows what types of restaurants have the
most violations turns out to smoothies
and cafes the fewest Indian Latin
Caribbean Spanish Thai have some of them
some of the most and you get individual
confidence intervals for each of them so
that's that comes from visualizing many
models there's a chapter of this and I'm
in our for data science chapter 25 that
if you're interested in visualizing
multiple models is really worth checking
out who has created lists columns with
summarize before trick number five is a
story of a couple of tricks in one that
combine to fire or to form something I
do a lot especially in these um in these
screencasts it's actually my favorite
plot so when I ask someone what their
favorite plot is some people say
something like oh I really like a really
particular compliment ARDS the poliana
k-- war and some could praise a plot
like this but the truth is I really like
I'm sorry I really like a plot like this
a bar plot that's sorted so the um so
this actually in fact I showed this plot
earlier what I said what functions in
India are do I use the most and it's a
combination of four steps account an FCT
reorder a reorder who has used FCT
reorder or built in read reorder before
yeah it's so amazing for visualization
it turns this column into an ordered
factor which allows you to visualize it
in this kind of ascending way I phone a
GM call who has used to um call as
opposed to GM bar so if you've used
giome bar before you have to see you
might have to say stat equals identity
more recently you can say GM call
instead of um like GM column for that
and for and who's used cord flip code
flippers great because I think it's so
much easy to read and you can fit some
more text when you have a horizontal bar
plot
so that combination of tricks forms a
graph that I make a lot that these are
just five examples from some of the from
some of the the screencasts that I've
done of here's a bar plot here's the
here's the frequency of certain
categories you can stack them you can do
really a lot with this graph who has
used FCP lumped before continuing our
tour of forecasts so what's great about
lump is that you might have a lot of
levels and you want to combine some of
them into other so this is from one of
the our studio this is wonderful from
one of our studios fantastic sheet
sheets for factors of four cats and they
show if you have a vector of like a
couple of levels you can FCP lump it and
take all the less common levels can
combine them into other so I'll show in
an example from a screencast I'm going
to stand by this one I'm having a little
trouble with it with that clicker so
this this would data set of horror
movies that included their reviews as
well as their rating like PG PG 14 are
pg-13 and if I just did a boxplot it
would look like this it would look like
it'd be out kind of out of order there
are a few levels there there's only one
PG rated horror movie in this data set
and and there be these couple of levels
and it wouldn't be really useful so but
with two steps FCT lump and then as we
saw in the last trick FC kiri order we
end up with a much more interpretive
graph that combines all the rare levels
into other so really like FCT lump forth
before box plots bar plots counts things
like that who's used log scales before
so this is a tidy verse trick in the
sense that it is a ggplot2 function but
it's really also a data science trip
that i think is um is really important
and sometimes underappreciated so i've
actually somebody said that if I had to
give import advice to new data
scientists I might start with something
like well you must start with a specific
scientific question then if a nope it's
actual
the number one advice is try putting
your axis on a log scale why is it
important to put out an accident on a
log scale I'm going to show a couple of
data sets where it's really pivotal one
is this some is this is a was a wine
data set what we said what is the
distribution of prices of of wine and if
we looked at it out on a regular scale
it would look it would see everything
interesting is crammed into one tiny
part of the graph put it in a
logarithmic scale one on which every
every fixed amount of space on the
x-axis represents a multiplication of
the value from ten a hundred a thousand
and suddenly becomes kind of more of a
bell curve shape this is a distribution
statisticians called log normal I mean
if the log of the of the data is
approximately normal why is it important
for it to be normal well what if we were
trying to predict a wine rating from the
price of wine we made a scatter plot
like that who said here's the price
here's how I'm experts rated this wine
everything will get crammed together and
the prediction wouldn't be very
effective in fact if in fact it would
quickly go off past a hundred whereas if
we if we do a prediction of the wine
rating based on the price of wine we
have what amounts the closer to a two a
correlation till we see like a linear
correlation and a better prediction and
indeed in this sum in the screencast I
found it was considerably more accurate
to predict wine rating from from the log
of price rather than from the price I
want you to start visualizing it with
log scales you can see that so much real
world data is log normal I somewhat
suspect a lot more real world data is
log normal than normally distributed
examples are GDP per capita across
countries this was a visualization from
a from one on plastic waste and we saw
that on the x-axis is log GDP per capita
of a country y-axis is log co2 emissions
and if you um if you had them in regular
scales everything would have been
crammed into the lower-left population
across cities or countries in come
across people ISM is
log-normally distributed revenue across
companies a lot of day usually these
days if I open a dataset and it's um
I almost so expect a numeric column to
be unless it's something artificial like
a test score I have you I often expect
it to be log normally distributed and
throw some scale X log 10 onto the graph
moving on to a couple tidy are functions
who has used the crossing function from
tidy our crossing is amazing and um and
what it does is is a little is fairly
simple what it does is it takes vectors
and finds every creates a table with
every combination of them here there's
um a which is 1 2 3 then a couple other
vectors and it turns into all 24
combinations of a B and and C the inputs
has anyone use expand dot grid expand
doc rid is the basic are equivalent
crossing is a little more convenient for
working with other Khidr functions
because among other advantages it
returns a table and doesn't convert
strings to factors it's really hard to
explain in two minutes what crossing is
so useful for it's really worth a talk
or a blog post on its own but some of
the things I would do with it are try
every combination of of two num of two
numbers so that I can so you can
visualize do you plot a mathematical
curve when it's used alongside augment
from broom it's really good for for
showing how a prediction comes from
particularly input parameters in this
case this shows that over time the
probability of getting a season cue has
become more dependent on audience
opinion and there's a really basic idea
of Tidy simulation we can use cross and
create all combinations of possible
inputs and end up doing some tidy
simulation on top of those all I can do
for now is advertise the existence of
the function it's real it's been really
powerful you end with two more tidy art
tricks for cleaning your data who is you
separate from tidy are actually about
half the room and this is from another
one of
our Studios cheat sheets separate takes
a column that like sound like a ratio
and splits it out based on a regular
expression or based on a on a string so
it's hard to appreciate how important
this is until you've worked with some
data where a lot of stuff is crammed
into one column this was a data set I
had to work with it during my graduate
work and that that all everything to the
right of name is all one column split up
by pipes with lots of really interesting
information back when I was in graduate
school actually went back to my code and
found this awful line for split for
extracting one value out of there there
one that I really needed today what I
would do is I would say separate how
tell it all the columns I want to be
divided into and give it a regular
expression a pad a string pattern they
would say here's how it split it and get
it in five separate columns so once you
work with data in the wild that has
these combined together separate is a
really handy trick the last trick I'll
introduce is extract who's used extract
from tide er before extract is fantastic
when you when you have some data that's
not necessarily separated by a delimiter
but kind of trapped within some pattern
of a of a column so here these were as I
did a sort of Bob Ross episodes and we
had these um codes these C's in an
episode so what I what I would do here
is extract from that episode column the
tube I'd say there's a regular
expression for s something E's something
and um and from that I get two columns
of season and episode number it's even
really helpful that by saying convert
equals true I get those columns as
integers it actually figured out that
those were integer columns and and
converted them and so that I wouldn't
have to do that myself so steps like
this can take three or two or three or
four steps of data cleaning turn them
into one so that concludes my ten tidy
verse tricks now um why do I like to
focus so much a trick what would tricks
what is so great about them is the tidy
verse nothing more than a bag of tricks
my take is that the tidy verse is
greater than the sum of its parts
I think that when you combine all of
these ways of doing something make every
one of them a little bit easier easier
I'm ensure that they all work together
fluently these benefits um they're not
just a little bit of communes here a
little bit of communes here they really
accumulate and keep you in your data
analysis flow and that's one of the
reasons that um that I've really liked
learning tricks from people when I pair
program with them when I talk to them at
a conference like this when I see it
when I read other people's code and I've
really loved sharing these ten tricks
with you today thank you
[Applause]